it's one year the anniversary this week
any regrets as you look back on what
happens during that period as to how was
handle with creditors what plenty
immediate of regrets we think it we were
elected with a mandate to reboot the
Greek economy and to renegotiate a loan
agreement and a fiscal consolidation
path that was a very unsustainable
fortunately the other side the track of
lenders were not interested in having a
rational discussion and we failed to
convince them the problem of course is
that given that we are continuing along
the path of the failed program Greece is
continuing to sink deeper and deeper
into the debt that inflationary spiral
and we miss this chance collectively
creditors lenders the European Union the
International Monetary Fund we miss this
great opportunity to we had to stabilize
Greece and take it off the headlines so
you don't have to have a program in
Greece again Alexis tsipras so basically
what you're giving is Alexis tsipras no
chance of fixing Greece so the question
of Alexis tsipras God and His angels
could not fix Greece based on their in
charge Alexis tsipras is the point I'm
making is yet even if you were God and
His angels in charge given the
constraints of this memorandum of
understanding this zone agreement it
can't be done that let's be practical
here can a broken economy like Greece be
mended by pushing almost every good and
service to the 23% v80 bond can we
possibly fathom recovery when businesses
small medium and large were forced in
the last couple of months of 2015 to
prepay a hundred percent of their
corporate tax for 2016 in 2015 this is
what you do to a country you want to
crash it not you want to allow it to
recover after eight long years of
permanent recession of continuing
continuing drops in nominal GDP the
debate tonight is on the pension reform
the Greece the creditors say needs to go
through
is Alexis tsipras on the wrong side of
that debate Alexis knows exactly what
needs to be done except he already
capitulated to a program at this
unsustainable let me put it very
succinctly the pension funds were saw
their capitalisation depleted completely
in 2012 when their capital was
effectively wiped out due to the psi2
the young haircut the pension funds were
forced to have to hold lots of Greek
government bonds and those were haircut
massively so the cut their pension funds
had a double whammy they were hit by
this haircut on and secondly they were
hit by the recession because the number
of people working in work and
contributing to the pension funds has
collapsed
you cannot mend this pension system
simply by cutting further because the
further cuts of the IMF for instance
insist upon this belt tightening would
lead to a further decline in aggregate
demand and economic activity which
reduce will reduce employment further
and reduce the contribution to the
pension funds further we need to arrest
this crisis and you cannot do it simply
by cutting any more yeah they're
reviewing Alexis tsipras knows that yeah
he is pursuing this at this point in
time because he knows that it's ties to
review money it was very simple
he capitulated to a series of policies
that he knows will fail that were
imposed upon him by people who wouldn't
who know that they will fall so what's
he doing well it's what we've been doing
for five years in Greece extending and
pretending we have pretending that the
insolvency of the Greek state and of the
banking sector can be overcome by means
of new loans on conditions of measures
that shrink national income that cannot
work it would not work everybody knows
this I had a remarkable conversation
with somebody high up in the troika when
I was in the minister
I want the revealing names but I think
the s the essence is very simple this
person said to me look yes I agree with
you this program can't work but we're
committed to it politically so for you
to gain credibility as a government of
Greece especially the left-wing
government you have to accept it I
thought oh my god here I'm being told
that an economic reform program that
can't work
must be embraced by us by them and this
is what's happening Europe and the IMF
are in constant denial so will Greece
gets the review money will pension
reform be passed when if something is
unsustainable
I think it generally has to it I think
yes and yes the money will be there or
they may get better remember this is not
money for Greece
this is extending and pretending the
troika is taking money from one of its
pockets in putting it in another so the
Greek state borrows from the ESM to give
a vcp it borders from the s/m to keep
the IMF this is a man for Greece this is
not money that goes into some kind of
investment for recovery so the money
will be given because the the troika
wants to pay the troika this is
effectively the extending and pretending
exercise that we are witnessing the
pension funds will be cut the pension
funds the pensions will be cut this is
not a reform look taking a cleaver a
meat cleaver and cutting it's not a form
surgeries reform what we need it in
Greece was to find a way of putting
together our pension policies our social
security policies and the
rationalization of the funds together
with a development strategy involving
privatization involving using the assets
public assets of the state as collateral
in order to create a homegrown
investment stream into these capital
assets in order to improve their value
not just fire sales and to bring all
this together so that the profits from
these investments of the state can be
utilized in order to recapitalize the
pension funds while at the same time I
would be very much in favor of reducing
earlier diamonds this is a scandal in
Greece I have so many many early times
but not touch the lowest of the pensions
which is now what is going to be touched
so we should be doing exactly the
opposite of what we're doing but this is
what we're doing this is what it is this
is you say it's extending pretend how
but but all parties are playing the game
at the moment the reason why we had a
crisis was that the serezha decided not
to cut the music was going to stop at
the moment no this isn't why we're
having ed
Arabic crisis is that in 2010 the Greek
state was bankrupt if the powers had
been Europe and I am have decided to
cover up this bankruptcy treat it as a
liquidity problem with extend and
pretend else that's why we think Greece
is in the news the reason why you and I
are talking about it was not the syriza
was elected and said we don't think this
is sustainable but it isn't sustainable
in a single economist I know who
believes that this is sustainable yeah
and this it's a tragedy that we keep
extending and pretending a situation
which everybody understands to be
sustainable when does it stop being
sustainable again though we we're all
their loss of it you mean when will you
go back to life on stations these are
political events the economics is
definitely going to lead to another
flare-up injuries exactly when it will
happen it's impossible to predict it
will happen there's no doubt about that
but look let's split let's be
practically it is there a short-term
sorry a nice I suppose project this year
next year how long how long would you
give it I can't see stability even at
this bad equilibrium and deteriorating
equilibrium being maintained for more
than a few months but it is imposed it
really doesn't matter people are
suffering increasingly every day
Europeans Europe is fragmenting
increasingly as a result of the policies
that are being applied in Greece and
then a transfer to Portugal and
elsewhere look you've got to understand
one thing this was my experience there
has been no serious debate about how to
stabilize the Greek economy why because
Greece is collateral damage in a broader
game of brinkmanship between Paris and
Berlin Paris and Berlin have not worked
out what they want to do with the
eurozone the eurozone is not sustainable
yeah and the French national budget is
that which Berlin has its eyes set on
Greece is not going to be allowed to
still be stabilized just until and
unless the two great powers of Europe
work things out amongst themselves
Kurds leave Greece for a moment you set
up a new organization EU wide movement
the left-leaning organization the
question I think people are asking
themselves is London have you had any
conversations with Jeremy Corbyn of the
Labour Party
any interest from him enjoying my view
unlike many of my compatriots many of
the people in continental Europe is that
Britain is essential for the European
Union and for us who are interested in
democratizing the European Union who do
not accept the regime in Brussels like a
many Brits don't it would be a tragedy
if we did not have this conversation the
answer is yes where we are in
communication with the Labour Party
where community communication with the
Green Party well communication with lots
of people in Britain including
conservatives who have who want with us
to create an escape from this dreadful
dilemma false dilemma between either
accepting the brasses democracy free
zone that we have or fragmentation
retreating to the cocoon of the
nation-state there must be a third
better way and we have in communication
with many people in this country a
conversation with Gerry :
I'm not going to mention a precise
details about the communication is live
and quite productive actually yes our
focus as always a pleasure thank you
very much indeed for your time